so former president trump's impeachment  lawyers have left  on mass a lot of people are saying that  they are leaving like rats  leaving a sinking ship in total five  respectable lawyers  have left the impeachment defense team  this is really bad news for former  president trump because the briefs in  the impeachment trial  are due very soon and the team was  headed by a respectable lawyer named  butch bowers who  has experience representing very  high-profile politicians in particular  he represented former south carolina  governor mark sanford when he went on  his whole appalachian trail  argentina affair thing and bowers didn't  seem to be a crazy person he seemed to  represent mark sanford reasonably well  so let's talk about why all these  lawyers left in part two so  subscribe or i'll see you in court